You know how they refer to a Hilbert space or a Hilbert curve as a space-filling curve? I like to refer to Bryce as an authority-filling curve. Like he just – if there's a way to be in charge, Bryce will find it in approximately 3.8 seconds. And then Bryce will lord it over you. And so the solution to this would just be like, Bryce, shut up. Like just – I knew you when you were nobody. I'm not going to take this from you. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 120 recorded on February 16th, 2023.
你知道人们是怎么把希尔伯特空间或希尔伯特曲线称为空间填充曲线的吗？我喜欢把布莱斯称为权威填充曲线。就像他只要——如果有办法掌权，布莱斯大概在3.8秒内就会找到它。然后布莱斯就会对你颐指气使。所以解决这个问题的办法就是：布莱斯，闭嘴。就像——我认识你的时候你什么都不是。我才不吃你这一套。欢迎收听ADSP播客，这是2023年2月16日录制的第120集节目。
My name is Connor. To ADSP, the podcast episode 120 recorded on February 16th, 2023. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue part four of this five-part conversation with Zach Lane. Today, we talk about safety and C++, tuples, variance, reductions, and more. The most recent episode of Oxide and Friends, which is a podcast that I've been lamenting about her. It was about the they brought on the consumer i hope i get her name yet right uh yale grower um she goes by
我的名字叫康纳。欢迎收听ADSP播客，这是2023年2月16日录制的第120集节目。我的名字叫康纳。今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们继续与扎克·莱恩进行的这场五部分对话的第四部分。今天，我们讨论C++中的安全性、元组、变体、归约等内容。《Oxide and Friends》最近的一集，那是一个我一直在感叹的播客。它是关于他们请来了消费者，希望我没把她的名字叫错，呃，耶尔·格罗尔，嗯，她用的名字是
at yale rights which is y-a-e-l on twitter and they pronounced y-i-l y-i-l um and so they brought her on to talk about this rust you know safety memory safety and programming languages and one of the things that they actually brought up is that some analysis that I can't remember if it was what Google did with their Android code or some other company with some, they did some analysis of like where the most buggy code is. And it actually wasn't old already existing code. It was new code that was being written. And so that like, sure, there's already millions and billions of lines of C++, but like, it actually kind of made sense when you think about it, like the code
在推特上叫 @yale rights（y-a-e-l），他们把 y-i-l 读作 y-i-l，嗯，所以他们请她来谈谈这个 Rust，你知道的，安全性、内存安全和编程语言，他们实际上提到的事情之一是，有些分析——我不记得那是谷歌对他们的安卓代码所做的分析，还是其他公司对某些代码所做的分析——他们分析了bug最多的代码都在哪里。结果发现，实际上并不是旧的、已经存在的代码，而是正在编写的新代码。所以，就像，当然，已经有数百万甚至数十亿行 C++ 代码了，但当你仔细想想，其实这挺有道理的，比如那些
that's been sitting there for 20 years and kind of just working, like maybe there's a couple of bugs in it, but like that code probably, yeah, they probably ironed out most of those bugs. It's the new code that new programmers are writing. And like, that's the buggiest stuff. So like, if we did add that stuff, I think that like a majority of like a huge portion, at least of bugs that are being written in C++ could be fixed by like new features like this kind of So if we did add that stuff, I think that a majority of, a huge portion at least, of bugs that are being written in C++ could be fixed by new features like this kind of stuff that you're proposing, Zach. Yeah.
已经存在了20年并且一直在那儿默默运行的代码，可能里面有几个bug，但这些代码，是的，它们可能已经消除了大部分bug。反而是新程序员正在编写的新代码，那才是bug最多的东西。所以，如果我们确实加入了这些东西，我认为大部分——至少很大一部分在 C++ 中编写的bug，都可以通过像你正在提议的这类新特性来修复，扎克。是的。
By the way, I'm not proposing anything along those lines. I'm not going to get involved with the standardizing of language changes. That is not my area. I'm not signing up. Showing up on your pirate ship with a rust flag at the top of the C++ committee. But Connor, I think that the issue is that almost every piece of new software that gets written these days uses old software and builds on top of existing things. And so it may not be that there's a bug in the old code. It may be a bug in how you're using the old code,
顺便说一句，我没有提议任何类似方向的东西。我不会参与语言修改的标准化工作。那不是我的领域。我不接这活儿。把带有 Rust 旗帜的海盗船直接开到 C++ 委员会顶上。但康纳，我认为问题在于，如今编写的几乎每一段新软件都在使用旧软件，并且是建立在现有事物的基础之上的。所以，可能并不是旧代码里有bug，而是你使用旧代码的方式有问题，
or it may be that you're using it in a way where there's this known sharp edge to it, but you haven't handled that in your usage of it, or you've hit a corner case that nobody else has hit before. And that's really worth it. Most C++ code is written with preconditions, right, that are sometimes stated and sometimes implicit. You've hit a corner case that nobody else has hit before. And that's really good though. Most C++ code is written with preconditions, right? That are sometimes stated and sometimes implicit. And if you violate them, everything crashes, right?
或者可能是你在使用它时，它有一个众所周知的痛点，但你在使用时没有处理好，或者你碰到了一个别人从未碰到过的极端情况。这真的很值得。大多数 C++ 代码编写时都带有前置条件，对吧？这些条件有时是明文规定的，有时是隐含的。你碰到了一个别人从未碰到过的极端情况。不过这真的很棒。大多数 C++ 代码编写时都带有前置条件，对吧？这些条件有时是明文规定的，有时是隐含的。如果你违反了它们，一切都会崩溃，对吧？
And so what's that? Womp womp. Yeah, exactly. Like, you know, you're on your own, buddy. Right. Yeah, yeah. So, you know, so you have like all this existing code, which might be better than new code in the sense of people who work things out. But it also is probably written with an eye towards performance first over safety.
那会怎么样呢？砰砰完蛋。对，没错。就像，你知道的，自求多福吧，老兄。对。没错，没错。所以，你知道，你有所有这些现有的代码，在人们把事情琢磨透这个意义上，它可能比新代码更好。但它在编写时可能也是把性能放在首位，而不是安全性。
And so there's preconditions that if you don't meet, you get a crash. Whereas like, you know, the Rust model is more like, you know, there's a well-defined thing that happens and it's not a crash. Even if you get in some sense arbitrary results, it's memory safe. Right. Right. even if you get in some sense arbitrary results it's memory safe right right um and so you know your code is not correct because it's safe but it's not going to you know bring down the the airline or something you know yeah and i think i think the problem is that uh there's there's no appetite on in the c++ community for the the cost that um that we'd have to pay for instead of just adding library UB whenever we have some failure cases that needs to be fast that we don't want to properly deal with. The alternative would be to provide a deterministic error path
因此，这里存在一些前置条件，如果不满足，你就会遇到崩溃。然而，你知道，Rust 的模型更像是，你知道，会发生一件定义明确的事情，而且不会崩溃。即使你在某种程度上得到了任意结果，它也是内存安全的。对，对。即使你在某种程度上得到了任意结果，它也是内存安全的，对，对。嗯，所以，你知道，你的代码不正确是因为它安全，但它不会，你知道的，导致航空公司之类的坠毁，你知道的。嗯，而且我认为，我认为问题在于，呃，C++ 社区对于我们为了那些需要快速运行却又不想妥善处理的失败情况，而不得不放弃添加库未定义行为（UB）所付出的代价，是毫无兴趣的。替代方案将是提供一个确定性的错误路径，
and that oftentimes has a cost or it takes away implementation time and we just don't want to do that. Yeah, and I think, I mean, I get what you're saying, but I think that there's also a lot of people that I've heard say they embrace this idea as long as it's a mode right so in other words just like rust has this get out of free uh get a jail free card where you could just say unsafe and then you can go down to the bit twiddling that you need to do in some cases and then everything's built on top of you know that becomes the old legacy code that's been
而这通常是有代价的，或者会消耗实现时间，而我们根本不想这么做。是的，而且我认为，我的意思是，我明白你的意思，但我也听过很多人说他们拥护这个想法，只要它是一个模式，对吧？换句话说，就像 Rust 有一个免罪金牌，你可以直接说 unsafe，然后你就可以深入到底层的位操作，去处理某些情况下你需要做的事情，然后一切都建立在——你知道的——那些经过每个人长期以来如此大量依赖和使用、已经变得坚固的旧传统代码之上，你弄明白了可能存在的所有那些错误。然后你在上面编写的新代码，会经过借用检查器的非常、非常仔细的审查。这确实让我想到，如果我们想引入一个模式，一个针对标准库的确定性错误模式，在这里，如果违反了前置条件，所有错误情况都会给你一些异常或全局中止（abort）之类的东西，我们能够摆脱多少库未定义行为（UB）？现在，你可能会认为我们会摆脱所有的未定义行为，但肯定存在一些情况，其前置条件非常难以检查，或者
hardened because everyone's been depending on it using it so hard for such a long time you figured out all those all those errors that might be in there. And then the new stuff that you write on top is like very, very carefully vetted by the borrow checking. It does make me think if we wanted to introduce a mode, a deterministic error mode for the standard library, where all the error cases would give you some exception or global board or something if a precondition is violated, how much library UB would we be able to get rid of? Now, you might think we'd get rid of all of it, but there are certainly some cases where there's a precondition that's very difficult to check or
根本无法检查。有时其中一些检查字面上就是不可判定的。但我想知道，如果我们有一个能够检查我们所能检查之物的模式，我们能从中获得多少实用价值。我认为会有很大帮助。所以，我认为获得价值的方法是，你必须有一个安全模式，然后你必须拥有 C++ 库的一个最小子集——C++ 库中对安全模式友好的子集，对吧？所以我认为，你知道的——我一直在对任何愿意听的人说，我认为实际上应该大约有四个容器，其他一切都应该是适配器。所以我们应该有一个类似 map 的东西，实际上，但这个 map 应该是一个哈希 map，比如一个高质量的开放寻址哈希 map。
impossible to check. Sometimes some of those checks are literally undecidable. But I wonder how much utility we would have from checking the things that we from having a mode that checks the things that we can. I think a lot. So I think the way the way that you get value here is you'd have to have a safe mode and then you'd have to have some minimal subset of c++ libraries of the c++ library um that is safe mode friendly right so I think you know I've I've been telling anyone who will listen I think really should have about four containers and everything else should be an adapter. So we should have like a map kind of thing, actually, but the map should be like a hash map, like a high quality open addressing hash map.
然后我们应该有一个 vector 和其他一些东西，对吧？因为我不认为现在人们真的很在乎链表和基于节点的容器。所以你需要这种由真正通过构造保证高效的东西构成的基础，它们是非常连续的等等。使用像算法这样的东西，因为大概内存安全的东西将能够在算法运行的特定实例化中检查，它是否有内存安全问题？然后你就能随用随抓地使用各种东西，随着时间推移，你可能会引入一些具有略微不同需求和略微不同保证的新算法。但是，是的，必须要有库的支持，我认为绝对需要，事情才能行得通。随着时间推移，拥有略微不同需求和略微不同保证的新算法。但是，是的，必须要有库的支持，我认为绝对需要，事情才能行得通。但我想我们能做到。困难的部分在于让演进方面的人员、
And then we should have like a vector and then a couple of other things, right? Because I don't think people really care about linked lists and node-based containers very much these days. And so you need like this foundation of really efficient by construction things that are like very contiguous and so on. use things like the algorithms because presumably the memory safe thing would be able to check in your particular instantiation of this algorithm when it runs, does it have memory safety problems or not? Then you'd be able to use stuff, catch as catch can, and you'd maybe introduce new algorithms over time that have slightly different requirements and slightly different guarantees. But yeah, there has to be library support for it, I think, absolutely, for things to work. algorithms over time that have slightly different requirements and slightly different guarantees. But yeah, there has to be library support for it, I think, absolutely, for things to work. But I think we can get there. The difficult part becomes getting the evolution folks,
语言侧的人员，去啃一个非常、非常大的语言特性。这总是一场艰苦的战斗，并不是因为你知道他们很古怪、不想要它，对吧？总是因为他们必须把一切都考虑周全，因为一旦你把它放进标准里，就很难再改变任何东西了，而且我们通常会被我们标准化了的语义所束缚，所以他们想确保万无一失，这是可以理解的。所以你会遇到这样的事情，比如，我们获得的 concepts 的版本，我想大约花了两个半发布周期才完成，也就是晚了发布周期两三年。然后，呃，你知道，协程大约也是两个或三个周期，模块则超过了三个周期。所以，你知道，这些具有巨大影响的大型语言特性，基本上所有这些最终进入了
the language side folks, to bite off a very, very large language feature. And that's always an uphill battle, not because you know grumpy and don't want it right it's always because they have to think through everything because once you put it into the standard it's very hard to change anything and we're usually stuck with the semantics that we standardize so they want to make sure they get it right and that's understandable so you have things like you know like the the version of concepts we got was i think about two and a half cycles in the making of release cycles you know two three years late recycles and then um you know co-routines was about the same two or three um modules was more than three so you know these big language features that have like a large impact basically all all these things that landed
C++20 的东西，因为它们已经在路线图上待了很长时间，这将是又一个这样的东西。所以你在谈论，你知道的，如果有人现在正在致力于此，并且他们正在制作一个在 Clang 或 GCC 或其他什么中工作的实现，那需要多长时间才能将其标准化？我们在谈论的是，你知道。一个十年。
in 20 because they were on on on the roadmap for a long time, this would be another one of those. And so you're talking about like, you know, if someone was working on that right now and they're making an implementation that worked in Clang or GCC or something, how long would it take to standardize that? We're talking about like, you know. A decade.
那是 32 年或 35 年。而且，你知道，我认为我们在委员会里经常开玩笑说，你知道，库小组，你知道的，行动更快，完成了许多事情，更重要的是，我认为库的流水线通常常常，呃，对等待未来语言特性的承诺不感兴趣，因为，你知道，它们往往不会实现，或者需要很长时间才能实现。这绝不是因为语言演进小组没有做那么多工作把它放进语言里，你必须做更多的工作。
That's a 32 or 35 years. And, you know, I think we joke often on the committee that you know the the library group you know moves faster gets gets a lot of things done and and more importantly i think we often the the library uh pipeline is often um uh what uninterested in in waiting for uh the promise of a future language feature because, you know, oftentimes they don't materialize or they take a long time to materialize. And in no way is this because the language evolution group isn't doing as much work. It's just because you have to do a lot more work to put it into the language.
而这实际上，你知道，那是我们在库中做了许多其他语言——也许在语言中做会更好——的事情的原因之一，就是因为我们可以在库中行动得更快。是的。如果库里有什么你不喜欢的，别用它就行了。而对于语言语义，你只能被它套牢。语言元组。是的，我们应该。好吧，那个，我们本该做语言元组的。我们绝对应该做语言元组。
And that's actually, you know, that's, that's one of the reasons why we do a lot of things in the library that other length that, that maybe would be better done in the language. And it's because we can move, move faster in the library. Yeah. And if there's something that you don't like in the library, just don't use it. Whereas a language semantic, you're stuck with it. Language tuples. Yeah, we should. Okay, that one, we should have done language tuple. We definitely should have done language tuple.
我希望我们有语言框架和语言元组。我只是，尤其是在你谈论了 Haskell 之后，那是另一件我从不谈论的事情，那就是对我来说，在没有代数数据类型的语言中工作是多么困难。而且，是的，就像我们有积类型（product types），但随后有一半的语言就到此为止了。
I wish we had language frame and language tuple. I just, like, especially after you were talking about Haskell, and like, that's another thing I never talk about is like, it's so hard for me to work in a language without algebraic data types. And like, yeah, it's like we have product types, but then like half the languages stop there.
还有一些和类型（sum types），我会给你一些 union（联合体）之类的东西。但问题是，一旦你使用了它们，特别是当它是用非常棒的模式匹配设计时，它就是，是的，
And there are like some types, I will give you some like unions or something like that. But it's like, once you use them, especially when it's designed with really nice pattern matching, it's just, yeah, it's,
它非常，你的语言中没有那个会非常难受，现在我们将有 std::variant，然后我们可能还会有语言变体（language variant），因为我不知道，我看到在某个时候有人在提议一个，我——是的，曾经有过提议，但目前没有正在推进的。你知道，语言变体很好。我更在乎拥有一个语言元组。
it's very, it's one of those things. It's very hard to, to not have that in your language um which is now we're going to have stood variant and then we might have l variant and uh which is going to be the language because i don't know i saw at some point someone was proposing a i'm i yeah there there have been proposals but there's no there are none that are in flight right now you know a language variant is nice. I care far more about having a language tuple.
我几乎完全相反。就像，我觉得我们拥有的元组，你知道，在某种程度上很接近我想要的。那是斯德哥尔摩综合症，我的朋友。`std::colon::colon::get`。扎克曾试图让它变得更好。就像一个可辨识联合体（discriminated union）。我确实试图让它变得更好，但人们说我知道那是什么。语言元组很好。你能得到更好的语法，但它只是语法糖。
I'm almost the opposite. Like, I feel like the tuple we have is, like, close-ish, you know, to what I would want. That's Stockholm Center, my friend. Stood colon colon get angle zero angle. Zach tried to make that better. Like a discriminated union. I did try to make it better, but people said I know what that is. The language tuple is nice. You get better syntax, but it's just sugar.
因为区别在于，对于语言变体，你可以拥有的是一个可辨识联合体。所以你获得了所有的安全性。但现在编译器可以看到这个可辨识联合体。它知道这意味着什么。它可以对其进行推理，并且很多时候可以将其优化掉，对吧？所以你可以拥有所有这些最终归结为“哦，它只是个int，我懂你”的代码，然后它一路把int放进去，而你无法用库获得那样好的优化，所以它在本质上不同于我们在库中所能做的。好吧，我认为这很公平。不过对我来说，
Because the difference is with a language variant, what you can have is you get a discriminated union. So you get all the safety. But now the compiler can see the discriminated union. It knows what it means. And it can reason about about it and you can optimize it out a lot of times right and so you can have all this code that boils down to oh it's just an int i see you right and it just puts the int all the way through and you cannot get nice optimizations like that so it's different in kind than what we can do in the library no matter what i think that's fair i for
至少，我使用元组的频率要比使用类似变体的东西高出十倍。嗯，是的，这确实很真实。但我的意思是，问题在于，如果我有变体——关于它的另一件事是——如果我有 variant，并且我不需要做所有这些该死的访问（visitation），那么我会更频繁地使用它。但它太笨拙了。它是 `holds_alternative`。是的，它太笨拙了，我根本不想去碰它。这正是当布莱斯说那番话时我脑子里想的，我在想，嗯，这真的是因为你不需要一个“和类型”（sum type），还是因为我们拥有的语言变体
me at least though uh i'd use tuple 10 times more frequently than I would use a variant-like thing. Well, yeah, that's very much true. But I mean, the thing is, if I had variant, that's the other thing about it. If I had variant and I didn't have to do all this damn visitation, then I would use it more often. But it's so clunky. It's a colon-colon holds alternative. Yeah, it's so clunky that I just don't want to mess with it. That's exactly when, when Bryce was saying that I was exactly thinking that I was like, well, is that a really a function of you not needing a, some type or is it a function of the fact that the language variant that we
比什么都没有要好，但与 Rust 或 Haskell 拥有的相比，这里的一部分观点来自实现者的角度？
have is better than not having anything at all, but compared to like, you know, what Rust has or what Haskell has, it's, it's part of this is from, is, is my view from the implementer side.
因为在英伟达和我们的标准库中，你知道，我们有一个元组，而那有一个可怜的工程师，他大概花了两年的人生，仅仅为了让那个元组在我们的编译器和其他一些编译器中正常工作。而正确实现 `std::tuple` 的复杂程度，
Cause at NVIDIA and our standard library, you know, we have a tuple and that, and there's one poor engineer who probably spent like two years of his life just making that tuple work across, you know, our compiler and a handful of other compilers. And the degree of complexity
以及与之相关的缺陷和注意事项的数量，让我极度渴望拥有它。是的，你必须做这种奇怪的递归继承，然后你必须进行完全正确的函数调用，以命中那些被继承的数据成员中的正确一个。
in the correct implementation of std tuple and the number of warts and caveats that are associated with it make me greatly desirable. Yeah, the fact that you have to do this bizarre recursive inheritance thing and then you have to make the exact right function call that hits the right one of those inherited data members.
就像，如果你曾看进去过，你会想去洗个澡，它太脏了——那里面没有哪一部分是令人满意的。因此，拥有一个语言级的元组会更好，那是肯定的。但你知道，我永远不必去实现它，所以这就是为什么我说，我一直在说，好吧，你只需去使用它。不过，为 Boost.Hana tuple 做个广告，它是一个比元组好得多的元组，它在方方面面都更好。并且，我的意思是，我还想，你知道的，上周在委员会会议上我们简短讨论过一个提案，关于让聚合结构体（aggregate structs）与某些元组协议一起工作。我实际上希望我们能更多地朝那个方向发展，
It's like, if you've ever looked inside there, want to just you know take a bath it's so dirty like no part of that is satisfying and so having a language one would be would be better that's for sure but you know i never have to implement it so that's why i was saying i was saying right all right you just get to use it uh but you know plug for uh boost hana tuple it's it's a way better tuple than tuple um it's just better in every way and i i mean i would also like you know, plug for Boost HANA tuple. It's a way better tuple than tuple. It's just better in every way. And I mean, I would also like, you know, there was a proposal that we talked about briefly at the committee meeting last week about making aggregate structs work with some of the tuple protocols. And I would actually like us to move more in that direction um you know if i just make a struct that has you know like three members or whatnot like i i want to be able to treat that like a
你知道，如果我只是创建一个包含三个成员之类的结构体，嗯，我希望能够像对待元组一样对待它。因为比起创建一个包含三个有名字的成员的结构体，我更愿意人们创建一个包含三项内容的元组……而且，我希望我们最终能够朝着那个方向发展。我也希望我们能为进行元组索引获得更好的语法。以及用于诸如对形参包（packs）进行索引之类的事情的语法。所有这些，我认为都会极大地增强你必须用元组或形参包进行的任何类型的编程，特别是当你处在泛型上下文中时。是的。是的。是的，我同意。而且我认为这里有一场大风波，我想大多数听众可能并不知道，
like a tuple because i would much rather people create a struct that has three members that have names than create a tuple of three things um and uh i i i hope we are going to be able to end up moving in that direction. And I hope that we'll be able to get better syntax for doing tuple indexing. And also for doing things like indexing into packs. All of which I think will greatly enhance any sort of programming that you have to do with tuples or packs of things, especially when you're doing it in a generic context. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. And I think there was this big brouhaha which i think most listeners won't be aware of that um there was a guy trying to standardize uh this thing called um uh was it was it was it oh enumerate right so enumerate like it yields an enumerated view and what it does you give it a range and it produces um a sequence of pairs right and the first element of the pair is the index that you're
有一个家伙试图标准化一个叫做——呃，是叫 `enumerate` 吗？对，比如 `enumerate`——就像它产生一个枚举视图（enumerated view），它的作用是，你给它一个范围，它会产生一个由对（pairs）组成的序列，对的第一个元素是你所在的索引，下一个仅仅是该值——对该值的引用。这太棒了——大多数语言都有类似的东西，它非常方便，每个人都赞同。是的，Haskell 也有一个，我忘了它的拼写是什么，但 Haskell 有一个等等。所以问题是，他试图这样做，出于某种哲学原因，我不喜欢使用 `std::pair`，我也不喜欢使用 `std::tuple`。所以我希望像——我想给它它自己的类型，比如 `enumerate_t` 之类的。它里面有一个 `int` 和一个对 `T` 的引用，对吧，或者无论值类型是什么。他花了很长时间试图让它工作，以至于它差点错过了 C++23。我们在最后一分钟把它加了回来，因为每个人都知道它是好的。其他人已经实现过它了。
at and the next is just the value like a reference to that value and it's great like most languages have something like this it's really handy to everybody was for it yeah and haskell has one i forget what spelling is but the haskell has one and so on so the thing is that um he tried to do it where he was like uh you know i just for philosophical reasons i don't like using std pair i don't like using std tuple. So I want to make it like – I want to give it its own type, like the enumerated T or whatever. It's got like an int and a reference to T, right, or whatever the value type is. And he tried for so long to get that to work that it almost missed 23. And we added it back at the last minute because everyone knew that it was fine. Other people had implemented it.
它在 ranges v3 中。当你使用 `std::tuple` 或 `std::pair`（无论最终是哪个）时，这是一个已知数量。但他非常努力地把这个别的东西硬塞进去。这让我当时想到，就在你刚才提出这个话题的时候，如果我们有一个语言元组，没有人会关心这种类型的问题，对吧？就像语言元组和你的任何结构体一样，它们基本上会是同构的，你能够把它们当作同一种东西来对待。对吧？所以，是的，我真的很希望我们有这个。
It was in ranges V3. It was a known quantity when you used std tuple or std pair, whichever one it ended up being. But he tried so hard to shoehorn this other thing in. And it just made me think at the time when you brought this up just now that like, if we had a language tuple, no one would care about this kind of issues, right? Like the language tuple and whatever your struct is, they would basically be isomorphic and you'd be able to treat them as kind of the same thing. Right. So yeah, I really wish we had that.
但我们没有。我一说出“语言元组”，就捅了马蜂窝了。是的。是的。是的。好了。正如我所说，语言元组。是的，你说了。对，对，对。好了。我们到两个小时大关了。布莱斯，你想谈谈你的——关于我们正在重新审视的问题的某些内容吗？你还想重新审视那个问题吗？这又是另一个问题的例子，我们真的很想要那个不可交换的归约（non-commutative reduction），那个
But we don't. Opened up a can of worms as soon as I said language tuple. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. as I said language two-pole. Yes, you did. Yeah, yeah, yeah. All right. We're at the two-hour mark. Bryce, you wanted to talk about your – something about the problem that we were revisiting? Do you still want to revisit that? It's yet another example of a problem where we really want the non-commutative reduction, the the reduction or the the parallel reduction or
承诺不会对输入进行重新排序的归约、并行归约或折叠。我们在过去的节目中讨论过这一点，康纳，第25集，扫描（scan）具有这个属性，扫描说它不会对输入进行重新排序，因为它不能，而且，在许多并行平台上，没有理由你不能给予这个保证。本质上，它是一个仅仅承诺不会为了做 SIMD 东西而把事情搞混的归约。而且，这完全是有效的，并且非常有用。我非常想要它。
fold that promises it won't reorder the inputs we've talked about this in past episodes connor that episode 25 this property out of scan the scan says it will not reorder the inputs because it can't and um uh there's no like on on many parallel platforms um uh there's no, like on, on many parallel platforms, um, uh, there's no reason that you can't give this guarantee. Um, essentially it's a reduction that's just promising. It's not going to swizzle things around to do SIMD stuff. Um, and, uh, uh, that like that's per it's perfectly valid and it's very useful. Um, and I very much want it.
我的意思是，方案一，扎克提到的那个，就是你想要的，怎么称呼它？仅结合律的归约（associative-only reduce）？我认为，这个问题用并行化版本的 `adjacent_transform` 来解决性能最高。因为双重折叠有点像扫描，因为它需要那种非交换性；而第二种类型的方案，即滑窗方案，它只是一种类似模板（stencil）的东西——它实际上不必关心它的左侧性质。所以我很确信，你首先要做的是进行变换，把这三个元素变成一个布尔值，然后为完全可并行化的结合律运算做好准备。这就是为什么我的直觉反应是那样做。
I mean, solution one, the one that Zach mentioned, was the one you'd want the, what do you call it, associative only reduce? This problem, I think, is most performantly solved with a parallelized version of adjacent transform. Because the double fold is kind of scan like because it's it requires that non-communitivity whereas the the second type of solution the slide solution it's only a stencil like it doesn't actually have to care about like the left nature of it so i'm pretty sure you're doing your transform first to turn those three elements into a Boolean then sets you up for a fully parallelizable associative. And that's why that was my gut reaction was to do that.
是的。但你的观点是成立的。所以对于第一个方案，你绝对想要那种非结合的——抱歉，是非交换的、仅结合的。我不知道你们怎么称呼那个。其实，你知道 Futhark 语言吗？它是一种受 Haskell 启发——不，我不知道，我不知道你到底怎么称呼它。其实，你知道 Futhark 语言吗？它是一种受 Haskell 启发的——不，我不知道 Futhark 语言——呃，你只是在凭空捏造语言。你在这次播客里捏造了各种各样的东西。不，不，我的意思是，哦，好吧，这是——我的意思是，我们得结束了，不过在这里，让我们
Yeah. But your point is valid. So for the first solution, you definitely want that non-associative, sorry, non-commutative associative only. I don't know what you call that. Actually, you know the language Futhark, which is like a Haskell-inspired... No, I don't know i don't know what you call that actually you know the language foothark which is like a haskell inspired no i don't know the language foothark uh it's just you're making up languages languages drugs you're making up all kinds of stuff in this podcast no no no i mean oh well this is i mean we got to wrap things up but here let's
看看我是否还开着它？我开着 ChatGPT 吗？我——现在——我只是喜欢有时与 ChatGPT 进行对话。我确实开着它。你应该这么做，因为每次你使用 ChatGPT，那都是在使用英伟达的 GPU。所以尽管一整天都去用它吧。他们就得买更多 GPU 了。我开着聊天窗口。我问了它几个问题。
see if i've still got it open do i have chat gpt i now now i just like i like to have conversations with chat gT sometimes. I do have it open. You should do that because every time you use chat GPT, that's using NVIDIA GPUs. So just go use it all day. They'll have to buy more GPUs. I have the chat open. I asked it a few questions.
但我问的第一个问题是，用于编写在 GPU 上运行的代码的顶级编程语言是什么？它给了我一个包含六个语言的列表，我原以为 Futhark 会出现在上面，但它没有。它是 CUDA C++、OpenCL、Vulkan、OpenGL、Python 和 MATLAB。不管你怎么评价这些答案。但 Futhark 确实是一门语言。那是六个，是的。它是哥本哈根大学的一门语言，我想这么说，还有 Troels Henriksen，我采访过他，
But the first one I asked was, what are the top programming languages for writing code that runs on the GPU? And it gave me a list of six, which I thought Futhark, I was hoping Futhark would show up on, but it was not. It's CUDA C++, OpenCL, Vulkan, OpenGL, Python, and MATLAB. Say what you will about the answers. But Futhark is a language. That's six, yeah. It's a language out of the University of Copenhagen, I want to say, and Troels Henriksen, who I interviewed,
或者我和我在另一个播客上的其他小组成员采访了他。我们采访了他。无论如何，所有这些细节都不是必要的。也许我会把所有这些东西都剪掉。重点是这门语言既有一个 reduce，又有一个我认为是 `reduce_asoc` 的东西。我可能把它们的拼写弄错了，但它实际上确实有两个不同的 reduce，一个是完全结合且交换的，另一个是仅结合的。所以它是唯一一门我遇到的在 这两种风味之间做出划分的编程语言，这在你在 GPU 上时其实说得通，那是你最关心这类事情的时候。但是，是的，我们要讨论这个算法多久，它才会出现在英伟达的库里？我不知道。因为第25集，我不知道那是多少年前的事了。我觉得搞笑的是你居然能脱口而出第25集。
or me and my other panelists on my other podcast interviewed. We interviewed him. Anyways, it has all those details weren't necessary. Maybe I'll cut all that stuff out. The point is the language has both a reduce and I think a reduce underscore ASOC. I might have the spellings of those incorrect, but it basically does actually have two different reduces, one that's fully associative and commutative and the other one that's associative only. So it's the only programming language that I've come across that actually has a delineation
这也是你可能编造出来的。不，我知道。有些集数是我的最爱，第25集就是其中之一，因为我不得不在其他节目笔记中如此频繁地引用它，以至于它最终深入骨髓。因为我们的归约实现在 warp 内的工作方式，它将始终从左到右进行。而英伟达 GPU 恰好工作的方式是，线程块（thread blocks）的执行会按顺序进行，按照线程块编号的线性顺序，所以你知道，如果你有一个，你知道的，从 0 到 n 的网格，它将按线程块运行，比如 0、1、2、3、4、5、
between those two flavors, which makes sense, I guess, when you're on the GPU, that's when you care about that kind of stuff most. But yeah, how long are we going to talk about this algorithm before it shows up in an NVIDIA library? I don't know. Because episode 25, I don't know how many years ago that was. I thought it was funny that you just had episode 25 at the top of your head.
6，诸如此类，按顺序。现在，那并不是——任何时候你跟英伟达任何从事硬件工作的人交谈，他们都会向你指出，那并不是编程模型所保证的东西，你不应该依赖它。但这种情况已经持续很长时间了。所以它碰巧对我们有效。所以康纳，你负责剪辑这些，对吧？所以我对你有个请求。
Another thing you probably made up. No, I know. There's certain episodes that are my favorites and episode 25 is one of them because I have to reference it back to it so often in other show notes that it ends up being ingrained. because the way our reduction implementation and thrust works within a warp, it will always do it from left to right. And the way that NVIDIA GPUs happen to work, the execution of thread blocks happens to go in order, in linear order of the numbering of the thread block so you know if you have a you know a grid of you know zero to n it'll run in thread blocks what like zero one two three four five
你能不能随手挑出布莱斯说过的一段特别长的词，然后做那个 10 倍速处理？蒂姆，你这么做的时候太搞笑了。我觉得太好笑了。每次我在椅子上笑得前仰后合，每一次都是这样。这太棒了。这是极好的反馈，因为我其实从没有——我从未收到过关于那个剪辑选择的反馈，而且我一直在想，我确信在某个时候会有人说“你为什么不直接把它剪掉，而非得让他听起来像只松鼠呢，因为这很烦人”，但对于听众来说——但我只是——这个听众它让我
six yada yada um in order now that is not like anytime you talk to um uh anybody at nvidia who works in hardware they'll they'll they'll point out to you that that is not something that the programming model guarantees and you shouldn't rely on it. But it's been that way for a long time. So it happens to work for us. So Connor, you kind of edit these, right? So I have a request for you.
听到布莱斯用那种声音时感到高兴，当它听起来正像一只兴奋的松鼠时，而且太完美了，听起来就像在吸冰毒，听起来像一只兴奋的松鼠，而且太完美了，听起来就像在谈论冰毒，听起来像一只磕了可卡因的松鼠，它简直快要失去理智了，这太神奇了，这个播客——所以我其实不知道——就像你在取笑我，而我喜欢——这是我第一次听到这个，但我literally，我已经到了这种程度：我知道你会处于长篇大论的正中央。就像很久以前开始的那样，你会没完没了地谈论你的胡桃木家具，以及你如何有一位女设计师，她总是知道要为你买胡桃木等等。还有那张餐具柜（credenza）。一开始挺搞笑的。
Could you just take any particularly long sequence of words that Bryce has said just at random and do that 10x thing? It's so hilarious when you do that, Tim. I think it's so funny. Every time I'm laughing my ass off in my chair every single time. It's fantastic. It's great feedback because I actually don't – I've never gotten feedback on that editing choice um and i've i think my thought has been i'm sure at some point someone's going to say why don't you just cut it instead of making him sound like a squirrel because it's irritating uh to the listener um but i it just this listener it makes makes me
但随后，就像，我们实际上已经积累了一定数量的粉丝，人们是为了技术内容而收听的。保留一点，你知道，背景八卦、内部笑话什么的挺好的，但有时你会陷入这些题外话，上一次是什么来着——整个故事是你需要从东京的一家法国餐厅为女朋友的生日蛋糕获取一个食谱，持续了大约 10 分钟。是的，而在那结束时，我甚至对你说了，我说“好的，布莱斯，听众们，你们刚刚听到布莱斯以 10 倍速解释。”重点是他需要一个会说日语的人。我一定会把这加进去的。
happy to hear bryce with his voice like when it exactly sounds like a excited squirrel and uh it's perfect it sounds like it's speaking of methamphetamine it sounds like a excited squirrel and uh it's perfect it sounds like it's speaking of methamphetamine it sounds like a squirrel on meth like that's been injected with cocaine and it's just losing its mind it's amazing the podcast so i don't actually know what like you're making fun of me and i like this is the first that i've heard of this but i literally i i've gotten to the point where i know you'll be in the midst of a monologue. Like it started way back when when you would go on and on about your walnut furniture and how you're you had a woman who knew that she she was your designer and she would always know to get you walnut and blah, blah, blah. And the credenza. And it started off funny.
顺便说一句，没有人提起这个。我对听众非常失望。我确信你们当中至少有一个人会说日语。我完全忘了在一开始提这个了。我们在第 115、16 集开始了 GitHub 讨论区。它们棒极了。人们一直在提问。我们得到了你的担担
But then, like, we've actually built up a certain amount of like a following and people listen for the technical stuff. And it's good to keep a little bit of you know background baseball whatever inside baseball but like sometimes you'll go on these tangents like what was it last time uh the whole you had this whole story about how you needed to get a recipe from this french restaurant in tokyo for a cake for your girlfriend's birthday it lasted like 10 minutes yeah and at the end of it i even told you i was like all right bryce uh the listener, you just heard Bryce at 10x speed explaining. And the point is he needs someone that can speak Japanese. I'll be sure to include that.
面食谱。我的意思是，其实我很惊讶，竟然有那么多人关心我们谈论的非技术性内容。我们在推特和 GitHub 讨论区收到了两个不同的关于这个食谱的请求，现在它已经被添加到节目笔记中了。我很想听一个只有 10 倍速布莱斯的播客，名叫 TIDL。它下面只有一句话，
Nobody brought this up, by the way. I'm very disappointed in the listeners. I'm sure at least one of you speaks Japanese. I totally forgot to mention this at the top. We started our, at episode 115, 16, the GitHub discussions. And they've been great. People have been asking questions. We got your Dan Dan
就像一个 YouTube 频道。下面只有类似这样的字幕：“布莱斯想要一个食谱。”然后有三秒钟的乱涂乱画，“布莱斯想要一个食谱。”你知道，我女朋友很希望能有一个那样的模式。三秒钟的胡乱涂鸦，“布莱斯，你的食谱是什么？”你知道，我女朋友很希望能有一个那样的模式。她会很希望有一个她可以按下就能让你变成 10 倍速的按钮，对吧？只在短暂的时期内。也许有一次如果布莱斯无法参加
noodle recipe. I mean, I'm surprised, actually, how many people care about the non-technical stuff that we talk about. We got two different requests, one on Twitter and one on GitHub discussions for the recipe, which has now been added to the show notes. I would like to hear a podcast that's only Bryce on 10X called TIDL. And it just has, underneath it just says,
录制，而我需要搞点内容，我就会制作一个他的 10 倍速合集。然后，这就是我在开头要说的话。听着，各位，我们不想错过任何一个星期五。我们已经连续两年半没有错过一次了，但我们本来会错过的，不过作为替代，这里是为你准备的布莱斯。我很高兴知道。我希望
it's like a YouTube channel. Underneath it just has captions of like, Bryce wants a recipe. And that like, three seconds of just scribbling, Bryce wants a recipe. You know, my girlfriend would love to have a mode for that. three seconds of just scribbling, Bryce, what's your recipe? You know, my girlfriend would love to have a mode for that. She would love to have a button she could push that makes you 10X, right? Just for brief periods. Maybe one of the times if Bryce is not able to make it
其他听众不会因此感到烦恼，因为这让我非常高兴，尤其是能展现我的控制力，因为很多时候，如果你听过一些播客，布莱斯会发布关于事情必须如何进行的行政命令。他会说，哦，你得把它拼接起来，切成两半，确保你——而我说，布莱斯，我才不做那些事呢。这是一个低开销剪辑的播客。你知道人们是怎么把希尔伯特空间或希尔伯特曲线称为空间填充曲线的吗？
for a recording and I need to come up with some content, I'll just do a compilation of him at 10X. And just, that's what I'll say at the top. Listen, folks, we didn't want to miss a Friday. We've been two and a half years straight without missing one, but we were going to miss it, but instead, here's Bryce for you. I'm glad to know. I hope
我喜欢把布莱斯称为一个——一个权威填充曲线。就像他只要——如果有什么办法能掌权，布莱斯大约在 3.8 秒内就会找到它。然后布莱斯就会对你颐指气使。所以解决这个问题的办法就是：布莱斯，
other listeners aren't annoyed by it because it makes me very happy, especially to flex my control because a lot of times, if you've listened to some of the podcasts, Bryce will issue executive commands about how things must happen. He's like, oh, you got to splice this up and cut it in half and make sure you – and I'm like, Bryce, I'm not doing any of that stuff. This is a low overhead editing podcast. You know how like they refer to a Hilbert space or a Hilbert curve as a space-filling curve?
闭嘴。就像，我认识你的时候你什么都不是。我才不吃这一套。好了。当你在的时候，我们需要从扎克那里得到更多猛料，因为现在我已经有两个冷开场了。
I like to refer to Bryce as a, as a, an authority filling curve. Like he just, if there's a way to be in charge, Bryce will find it in approximately 3.8 seconds. And then Bryce will Lord it over you. And so the solution to this would just be like, Bryce,
我说过我只打算用一个。你还有什么？好吧，我们至少得弄到。扎克，你要去哪儿吗？我们至少得弄到一个扎克军团的故事，因为它们都太搞笑了。请务必查看节目笔记中的链接，了解我们在今天的节目中谈到的所有内容，以及如果你有任何意见和问题，可以访问 GitHub 讨论区的链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
shut up. Like, just, I knew you when you were nobody. I'm not going to take this. All right. We need to get some more hot pigs from Zach while you're on because now I've got two cold open.
闭嘴。就像，我认识你的时候你什么都不是。我才不吃这一套。好吧。趁你在线，我们需要从扎克那里再弄点热乎的爆料，因为现在我有两个冷场开场了。
I said I was just going to use the one. What else can you? Well, we have to get at least. Do you have to go anywhere, Zach? We have to get at least one Zach Army story because they're all hilarious. Be sure to check the links in the show notes for all of the things we talked about in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion if you have any comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我说过我只打算用一个的。你还能怎么样？好吧，我们至少得弄一个。扎克，你要去哪儿吗？我们至少得听一个“扎克军队”的故事，因为它们都太搞笑了。请务必查看节目简介中的链接，了解我们今天节目中讨论的所有内容，以及如果你有任何意见和问题，还可以查看 GitHub 讨论区的链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。